he is none other than Mike home burn
here on the Richards Joe how are you
Mike I'm doing well rich happy new year
right back at you right back at you you
know and I thought of you about this
weekend because obviously with the
Packers and the 49ers playing each other
you know many people clearly and
obviously would associate you with
Seattle although those might be the
Millennials in this mix you are hired by
Bill walls to be Jim Montana's
quarterbacks coach is that yeah that is
a true story right that is true yeah
what in the world was that interview
like Mike well I went in there and I was
a San Francisco guy and I had always
gone to as a as a coach I'd always go on
and visited the 49er training camp out
of my area because I was there in the
summer and so I knew a couple of guys on
the staff and I and a friend phoned me
and said the quarterback coach is
leaving Paul Hackett he's leaving the
49ers why don't you apply for that job I
said now they're not kind I'm only been
in college coaching for a couple years
but he goes no really once you try and
so I phoned a couple of guys got the
interview anyway and I think well Bill
was great and and and then he was very
honest with me said Mike I've got a
couple guys in mind and it was you had a
great interview but I got a couple guys
in mind if they want the job then I'm
gonna go that way so I said okay thank
you limit for the experience I thought I
learned a lot and then I was jogging
when we're gonna be at lunch at BYU and
and the secretary says a mr. Walsh phone
I said you were out jogging I said what
so I raced back in and long story short
he he offered me his position and it was
it was really something to be able to go
back to my hometown and coach and not to
mention we have a pretty good
quarterback to coach yeah right yeah I
always tell people don't wasn't very
good until I got there well that's a
good story to tell for sure and it's
interesting because right now we're
talking about how how Aaron Rodgers has
taken to Lafleur's coaching Matt
Lafleur's coaching or Lafleur has
changed his style maybe to suit Rodgers
we were
none of us are really at the granular
level here but what is that what is that
philosophy like I mean what does that
like to be a coach with a guy that's
already been there and on that trophy in
the case and you show up obviously the
difference between position coach and
head coach but I'm wondering if we can
draw a parallel here for those listening
and watching you know it's interesting I
I when you brought up to my time of the
49ers I remember I've been in work there
about two weeks and Bill walked in and
said listen Joe's coming over today I
want you guys just go get a coke and and
get to know each other a little bit and
I was thinking the whole time in this
guy's already won two Super Bowls MVP of
the league what in the world can I teach
him or how how is this gonna work
and he came in Joe came in we started
walking down the hallway and he goes
Mike before we go any farther listen I
want you to coach me hard quote/unquote
I want you to coach me hard if I'm doing
something wrong you tell me if you want
me to do something I'll listen and and
right away it changed everything I my
anxiety or any anxiousness I had you
know when any he was great that way and
it kind of set the tone with how I could
approach quarterbacks all the
quarterbacks ever coached in the NFL and
there was a great player who did that
and I think Aaron the quarterback that
whoever the coaches and the quarterback
like an Aaron Rodgers you have to have
trust in each other you have to believe
in one another you have to kind of click
or have some sort of a moment there
where you're going okay I'm with you and
you're with me and and that that appears
to have happened this year yeah I was
there and yeah yeah it's it's hard when
you're going in and there's a superstar
there he's he's set in his ways he's
learning a new offense and you know but
you as the coach that's what you're paid
to do you're paid to make it work
somehow
so as the adult in the room you got to
figure out how to do that and then I'm
wondering what you could tell me how it
was for you as a first time head coach
in the NFL to walk in a Lambeau Field
you're now the head coach of the Green
Bay Packers urine technically a
descendant of Lombardi here at the
position and what Lafleur might have
been going through on that front
this year like well you know what rich
and I probably you know we've known each
other long
I probably have told you the story
before but when I went to interview
there I walked into the lobby the old
lobby there and they had a collage of
Bart Starr and coach Lombardi and all
these pictures all over the place and I
went wow you know Here I am I'm getting
interviewing for this job and then when
I got the job then it was kind of
business as usual and I kind of knew I
kind of knew that I couldn't be coach
Lombardi and everyone had it's funny how
people viewed the coach of the Green Bay
Packers and so I think it's very
important to be your own person but then
walking out the first game and never
forget it in in preseason walking out
through that little narrow opening out
into the field and it was like surreal
and I thought it was okay to enjoy the
moment this is pretty cool myself you
know I don't know how exactly how I got
here but this is pretty cool and then
when did you hire Andy Reid who has got
a shot at getting back to the Super Bowl
this weekend with the Chiefs what was
that process like Mike how do you get on
your radar screen and all that good
stuff
well Andy actually was my first hire and
I had it be Yui at one of my jobs I was
a quarterback coach but then one of my
jobs that I was in charge of the
graduate assistant coaches and you know
every school we had I think we had about
six of them mmm Andy was one of those
guys he had just finished school there I
think he was in graduate school helping
out coaching the football team and right
away you know we clicked and our
personalities clicked and and I knew I
know it's easy for me to say that now it
gives you such a great coach but I knew
then this guy's this guy's going places
and I was able to help him get some jobs
early on in his career and I said if I
ever get a head job I'm phone-in you and
that's what I did and and he was the
first guy I hired anything he goes when
don't tell him how old I am so he was
young this is it well they're gonna find
out I mean so I just texted him the
other day but and I said listen yeah
I'll be honest with you I'm I hope he
goes all the way I'm really pulling for
him
but I said you know well you really
congratulations go get it keep your head
down and just go and but I said you got
to do something about your mustache it's
really a little over the top well I mean
you can also speak from experience on
that front right about about how to
maintain and yeah I mean because at
least at least mine is a little bit
controlled I mean I said you gotta do
something he goes you know what he texts
me back you know I did look at my press
conference it is a little bush a little
well I mean I guess he's focused on it
on other matters Mike Holmgren here on
the Rich Eisen show what has he done to
the offense that obviously the that when
you strip it down whatever he's doing
right now it can be it can be boiled
down with a lot of the stuff that you
were doing with San Francisco and
brought to Green Bay and him seeing
taking a little bit of here from a
little bit from there maybe from his own
experiences but what we're seeing from
Kansas City right now and praising for
its innovation and its and its its
diversity I'm wondering what you're
seeing Mike well you know what I phoned
him or texted him and I said you know
what or maybe what mitt was a phone call
it being any season and I said you know
what you got a great team good luck blah
blah blah I said be you you've forgotten
everything I've taught you I don't
recognize anything that you're doing out
there and he laughed and he goes no
actually if we sat down we're doing a
lot of same stuff we might it might be
disguised a little bit but it's a lot of
the same stuff and the more I watched
his team this year
mm-hm it is you know a special emphasis
on their great tight end they use him a
lot now the motions and the college game
you know it has that has come into the
NFL they do that but they also have the
right quarterback to do that stuff and
so it's it's fun to watch his offense I
mean they are really good and I think I
think in this game rich I think they're
gonna need it
because I think Tennessee brings a
different style but but every bit as
effective well I mean have you seen any
I mean you've seen a lot of football
Mike the artist for itself but anything
like Derrick Henry
and how he has provided many business
decisions for some stellar defensive
players to make them think twice before
they try and wrap and take down I mean
he has been something else anything
anything that you've seen that comes
close to what Derrick Henry has put out
on the field here Mike you know it's
been remarkable he said he's had quite a
run and you know his offensive line also
has a lot to do with that but the
closest comparison because you're always
asked to make comparisons yeah III
equate him with Eric Dickerson I you
know Eric was a big back went against
him many many times and he could he was
very you move great but he could also
damage if you tried to tackle him
improperly so that's why I think of when
I think of him I really do and I don't
know if Derrick Henry is as fast as Eric
was but there's some similarities there
I think yeah I mean the way Eric ran
straight up right and then was coming
right down a hill and just slash and
then suddenly that's it's an eight-yard
gain that becomes 30 40 50 that's an you
know without the goggles obviously an
excellent comparison yeah you know I
mean it's just been something else ask
the poll question of Mike home burn
Chris Brockman I'd love to get his his
thoughts on that subject yeah coach
which Super Bowl matchup do you think
that we're gonna get Chiefs Packers
Chiefs Niners or Titans Packers Titans
Niners what do you think I think I think
the games are all going to be closer
than people think but I think it's gonna
wind up to be the Chiefs and the Niners
I I think but I think they're gonna be
great football games I can't wait to
watch am I now that I don't have any
skin in the game and I don't have any
stress to deal with I like it back and
have a have a little lemonade and watch
the game I like it very good you know
Chris Mike is famous for a lot of things
but he's not as famous as I'd like for
the 40-yard dash that I run every year
and is now for charity I would not have
done it a second time I would not I did
it once and I had no real plans to do
with a second time until a certain coach
of the Seattle Seahawks saw me at the
combine the next year and said you've
got to do it again that's correct Mike
right isn't that true that is absolutely
correct and I
I applaud you for doing that but rich
I'm a little older than you are a lot
older than you are just I I have to just
warn you now them and the muscles they
tend to tighten up just get as you get a
little bit older so be careful I know
stretch it's like you told me that when
I was much younger to that very year you
said the training staff ready if you're
gonna do it again but you you really up
serious Mike you were like I remember
walking into the old RCA Dome through
you know that revolving door where you'd
felt the burst of air come through
because of the way that they would prop
the stadium up with the air conditioning
and you came up to me you're like you
can do that run again are you I'm like I
don't know and you were like consistent
oh no no you're like one of my players I
said yeah you're gonna do it you're
gonna get this thing done and you said
okay I did in year after year you've
always been such a great supporter on
that mic so thank you I appreciate the
call too
all right but any time for you okay
thank you appreciate that that's Mike
Holmgren
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on VR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app